[Music]
from software's new project
shadows die twice they've given us
13 seconds of footage to work with but
in a way
the less there is the more there is to
talk about for example have you noticed
the japanese script in the background
or the oriental instruments what about
those
shavings in the corners or the chisel
that likely caused them
which components of this mechanism move
first
is this phrase a name or a tagline
and will all my theories be proven wrong
in a day or
12 months listen on and let's find out
now everyone's first impressions
including mine
was that this looks like bloodborne 2
right
in fact my first thought was that this
mechanism looks a lot like a trick
weapon
goemon's long-handled scythe in
particular
furthermore the tense cord could be
fortified with blood just like
trick weapons are fortified with blood
gems and
it's very likely that we're seeing this
mechanism tested or
even attached to an arm in some way but
more on that later
next the phrase shadows die twice
it's worth noting that there's a full
stop after this phrase
which indicates that it's not a game
title and that it's more of a tagline
like prepare to die shadows die twice
it carries themes of death and
resurrection
which are two very heavy themes of
souls-like titles
obviously in bloodborne in particular
shadows crop up a number of times
there's the orphan of cos
whose shadowy spirit arises from his
mother
there are the shadows of yharnam and
there is really the concept of dying
twice
in bloodborne because you can die both
in the waking world
and in the nightmare realm where your
consciousness resides
lastly the font of shadows die twice
resembles libra baskerville or garamond
which are fonts that are almost
identical to bloodborne's menu
and item descriptions but now how many
of you guys noticed all the oriental
themes
in the teaser many characters in the
background appear to be
really elegant kanji written vertically
as many east asian scripts can be
in addition have a listen to these
instruments
that's an oriental flute for sure maybe
a
shakuhachi or a side blown kung fu flute
now listen to the drums
these could be taiko which is japanese
drumming that's
commonly used for dramatic tension
so bloodborne and an asian theme
hmm there doesn't seem to be much
overlap at first glance
until you remember yamamura the wanderer
who was locked in an underground cell
just past ludwig where his secrets decay
in the fallow darkness yamamura sports
the garb of a distant eastern land
and once pursued a beast for honorable
revenge
before becoming a hunter of the league
he wields a chicago
which is a blade forged in said eastern
land
there are of course other lands outside
of yharnam's gothic victorian
themes and yamamura is our link to them
could he have been our blood-borne
teaser character for shadows die twice
all along kind of like how chester was
our teaser character for bloodborne in
dark souls
maybe if bloodborne was to have a
successor i've
always thought that it would really need
to shed
the stale gothic theme that it has and
lovecraftian feudal japan would be this
perfect
spin for bloodborne 2. now
do i actually think it's bloodborne too
not really
honestly it almost feels too obvious
based on that trailer
like that's what they want us to think
and miyazaki has said that he doesn't
want to work
on soulsborne sequels for several years
if ever and also i hope it's not
bloodborne too
fromsoftware does a way better job with
new ips and
new spiritual successes rather than
sequels
in my opinion and bloodborne is just a
beautiful game on its own
and i don't really want another console
exclusive
please don't take away my pc cheat
engine camera angles
anyway regardless of which game this
turns out to be
we've established this oriental theme as
a certainty
and putting aside these distant
references of eastern lands that we see
in bloodborne and dark souls as well
remember that fromsoftware has worked on
heavily japanese themed
games in the past namely kuwan
and tenchu let's take a look at these so
tenchu
is a third person stealth game based in
feudal japan
with sort of demonic themes simmering
just below the surface
many of these tenchu games carry the
word shadow in their titles
and a couple of characters keep on
coming back to life
and i found this cutscene referencing a
main character's shadow
i sent my shadow far and wide across the
land
as for the mechanism in the teaser and
its references to tenshu
where there's a theme of puppets and
reanimated skeletons
and some even speculate that this
mechanism is a reimagined grappling hook
which plays a role in tenshu and some
people are even saying that there's a
kunai throwing dagger embedded within
the red cord
it's sort of hard to tell if you can see
it here or if it's just the metal
twisting
have a look another possibility is kuan
which is a survival horror game that was
developed
for the playstation 2 by from software
kuwan has maybe one reference to the
teaser
trailer that i could find namely this
jump scare sound that is almost
identical
to the string-based jump-scare sound of
the trailer
next i should probably mention shadow
tower which
i'm literally only mentioning because it
has the word shadow in the name
it's this first person dungeon crawler
which is similar to some of the king's
field games that inspired demon souls
but again not that much of a
relationship here except the name
and finally demon souls demon souls has
an arch stone that is called
the archstone of the shadowmen which
leads to all the shrine of storms levels
now these shadow men are said to worship
storms
mourn the dead and reside in other
bodies
there's also the sound of a storm
happening in the background
of the teaser trailer and from software
and
partners did all recently shut down all
of their demon souls servers
in anticipation of a sequel perhaps or
perhaps not
because i have to say as fans who are
sort of confronted
with something that we don't recognize
it's almost natural for us to have this
tendency to
cling to what we know bloodborne count
shadow tower tenchu demon souls it's
just as likely to be
none of these things and a new ip
altogether
so don't get me wrong the only reason i
don't talk about it as much
being a new ip is there's not much for
me to talk about beyond
saying it but in the spirit of analysis
let's look at what could be happening in
this scene with less bias this time
firstly this metal tool with a wooden
handle jutting from the parchment
seems to be a part of a screwdriver or
more likely a chisel
i lean towards chisel as it explains the
shavings that
might be appearing in the top left and
the bottom right
was the bone being stripped or something
beforehand
secondly the entire mechanism wavers
gently in the early frames
as if it's suspended in the air the
first part to move
is actually this lighter blood-stained
chunk that's connected
to the top of the bone and the bone is
almost
certainly the bone of an arm or a leg
next to move is the cord which is pulled
taut but it moves independently of the
first motion i just mentioned
in the top left it's almost as if
there's something in the bottom right
causing tension as well in fact most of
the twisting
related to the cord is actually taking
place at the base of the cylinder
in the bottom right indicating that
there is a lot of pressure being
generated
from within the sheath in this direction
basically there's so much going on off
screen that it feels
pretty impossible to know for sure what
this is
i've watched it hundreds of times today
so now i
can't wait to see what it actually is it
could be
a winch mechanism which is something
used to
haul or lift but it doesn't seem to be
lifting anything
just tightening and creating tension
so it might be more of a turn buckle
mechanism which
was used to create and maintain tension
i imagine this would have been used in
those old torture devices that
pull people apart so could it be a
corpse
attached to a pulley torture system
obviously torturing a dead person
or their bone is redundant but the title
is shadows die twice which indicates
that there might be a reason to kill
someone a second time and after all
skeletons are reanimated in pretty much
every from software game
why not now and finally could it be a
mechanically
augmented arm or body of sorts a sort of
medieval take
on human augmentation with mechanisms
instead of
technology would be a pretty crazy new
area to dive into but in conclusion
at the very least it looks like we can
expect more information within the next
12 months
and likely even a release date in late
2018
my source is yasuhiro kiteo who used to
work for sony on bloodborne
and who now works for from software in
addition there could be a trailer at psx
in a day or so which is
really soon christmas seems to be coming
early for souls fans and i think i'm
always going to be here
telling you kind of why these gifts are
awesome
i can't wait to see what you guys think
in the comments because it's been the
first time in a long time that we've
talked about something new
on this channel and i'm really excited
and tired
because it's 4am but i'll talk to you
guys again soon
also in the last video we held a vote
for which video
i should work on next and the winner was
the shared timeline of soulsborne so
thanks to everyone who became a patron
to vote i really appreciate your insight
into the channel
so thank you and i'll see you again soon